- But you like to get out sometimes though
'cause I heard that Harrison Ford,
did he spill wine all over you once?
- Well, yeah, I was at party.
- It's a good story.
- This is years ago
- Okay.
- at Carrie Fisher's house,
Carrie Fisher and Penny
Marshall used to do
a joint birthday party every year.
- Okay.
- So I went and
Harrison Ford was everybody
there was a celebrity.
- Oh.
- And it was so weird.
- I've never been to that party, yeah.
- It was such a strange, it was like being
in like Madam Tussauds
because they were all famous
- Yeah.
- and it was just like walking in
and then Harrison Ford
was like walking through
with like three glasses of red wine
in like little plastic cups, like.
- Okay.
- And I mean,
he should be able to carry them
'cause he's Indiana Jones and Han Solo.
So he should be able to carry
three glasses of wine.
- What a let down.
- But he like walked up and
he goes, whoa and he fell
and threw all of the wine on me, like all,
but it was so, but it was him.
- You were like, fine.
- I was like, it's fine.
I mean, I was kind of really excited,
I was really star struck.
I was really excited.
- Was he so embarrassed?
- He was so embarrassed
and he was like, he
had, he grabbed napkin,
but it was on my front.
And he was like, oh, oh.
- So I can't pat it down.
- Didn't know what to do
and it was just the most adorable thing.
- I love it.
- It was really, really sweet.
- I love that you're like
Han Solo, Indiana Jones,
what an epic fail.
- I mean he could have
just whipped off the stain
- Yeah, yeah.
- maybe, but I don't know
like he's just very, it
was a really exciting,
it was one of my favorite
celebrity moments.
- I love that.
- That was exciting.
- Yeah.